ah
I'm in the office of the world's richest
man and I'm here to convince him to save
the planet
now you've heard of him I'm sure boy
Genius billionaire Eric Steele CEO of
Steel Technologies ten years ago back in
2025 Steele made his fortune by
inventing a new cryptocurrency K coin
now it's the billion dollar backbone
that funds every one of his latest
business ventures I mean five minutes of
this man's time
cost more than my house
and he's got his hand out
[Music]
he is supremely smug wearing cowboy
boots in a tight black shirt and he's
smiling you know seems like he's always
smiling
in all honesty I don't feel good about
my chances of persuading this plutocrat
but I have a backup plan
you see Steel's bodyguards patted me
down before I entered his office
but they didn't find what I'm carrying
in my pocket I can feel their hands pass
right over because it's very small small
but powerful
okay
let me back up a bit my name is Mark
Alpert and I'm a science journalist I
used to write articles about
astrophysics but after the California
dust bowl of 2029 the wildfires of 2031
I became a climate change Crusader I
mean when the entire planet is burning
what's the point of writing about
anything else
foreign
[Music]
the ironic thing is when I first met
Eric Steele I thought he was one of the
good guys
I mean he had a fantastic idea for a new
source of renewable energy
steel planned to build solar panels and
space
giant orbital arrays that would focus
sunlight on immense solar panels
you see
out in space 22
000 miles above the ground Earth
sunlight is more intense than it is down
here on the Earth
and there's no light tile so it's
continuous power always on exactly what
we need to get rid of gas and coal
plants forever I mean each orbital
station could generate 2 billion watts
of power and send it straight down
through the atmosphere via microwave
beams and then the receiver dishes on
Earth could stream all that clean
electricity into the local grid rain or
shine because microwaves can pass
through any weather
now
now I'm an astrophysics expert so I knew
Steele's project could work and he said
he'd lined up a hundred billion dollars
of investor money to fund a dozen
orbital space stations
[Music]
but it turns out that Steele's space
proposal
was a sham I contacted his Investment
Partners they said they hadn't agreed to
fund the orbital space stations
then a month ago
I figured out what had happened
steel was pivoting to a new idea
he called it
Sky Cove
this new idea Sky Cove had nothing to do
with clean energy instead it was a
luxury space station a huge uh
ring-shaped habitat hanging in low orbit
with recycled water and air and enough
supplies for hundreds of people to live
there for years but exactly who would
get to live there
can you take a wild guess
well I discovered that the price for
tickets aboard skyco would cost five
billion dollars a piece
the world's billionaires could continue
slow roasting the Earth and if things
got really bad say they ran out of water
for their swimming pools or the masses
stormed their Estates well plutocrats
could simply blast off to their orbiting
Mount Olympus and watch planet Earth
collapse from above
Steele was giving his fellow plutocrats
an excuse to do absolutely nothing
about global warming
so I wrote a story
telling all the facts the price of skyco
the perks all of it
public outrage was immediate headlines
and in every language demonstrations
worldwide nobody wants to gaze up at the
elite
while they
even the rest of us behind
[Music]
foreign
after my story published I got a package
in the mail it was from a whistleblower
an engineer in Steele's company who had
been fired and he was just as pissed as
I was that steel had pivoted from solar
power to skyco
the package contained reams of damaging
evidence
evidence that showed steel used
coal-fired power plants to run the
computer servers mining these
cryptocurrency
steel was funding Sky Cove with Dirty
Money he'd posed as an environmental
savior while his cryptocurrency burned
up more energy than New York City
the package also contained a flash drive
loaded with software
The Whistleblower said all I needed to
do was plug the drive into a computer
behind Steele's corporate firewall the
software would duplicate K Coins
instantly driving the price of his
cryptocurrency to zero the billionaire
would be bankrupt in minutes
but
I'm no Saboteur I'm a reporter I I
didn't want to keep the flash drive but
throw it away either
[Music]
so here I am
in Steele's office and he keeps
shaking my hand
finally let's go
I put mine back in my pocket make sure
the flash drive is still there
he's invited me here to space Corp
America his headquarters because he
thinks my article is unfair he wants me
to see his side of things he starts
blathering on about Sky Cove the
Innovations the advances I mean he's so
excited he can't sit still
finally I just cut in and ask him
what happened to the space Power idea
solar panels in orbit clean electricity
for everyone
still looks out the window
looks at me and says
the solar project
well just wasn't attractive enough for
investors
the wrists were too high
at the end of the day it's it's not my
job to slow down global warming but
that's the government's responsibility
you get it right it's just business
[Music]
my heart is pounding
dizzy and shaking I point it still and
say people like you control the
government I say you use your money and
your lobbyist to get anything that you
want
steel keeps smiling
relax he says we can talk about this
calmly can't we
[Music]
so I relax and I calmly ask him a few
more questions
after the interview is over
I tell him my editor wants the files
right away and I ask him if I can borrow
a computer
transmit them
steal nods but
he isn't listening he's staring up at
the sky
[Music]
Steel's secretary takes me to the
reception area and hands me a silver
laptop
I load the flash drive
all I have to do is hit enter and
trillions of dollars worth of steals
cryptocurrency will evaporate
just like all the lakes and Glaciers and
species for the last 100 years
if I hit enter
skyco gets grounded his coal factories
in Russia go silent financial
institutions would Teeter maybe collapse
[Music]
if I hit enter it's also the end of me
as a journalist
or
or I could leave
do nothing just write my story and and
and Hope for Change
you know everyone keeps saying it it
feels like the world is ending
but I think it depends on who's the
author
too long I've been writing epilogues and
elegies
time for a news story
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]